hello everybody and welcome to part 15
of let's play from dust okay we're gonna
need OMAP here looks like some lavas
popping out here um
the first one is over there I think they
can make that can't they maybe I don't
know I might have to build him a little
bridge here cuz there seems to be some
gaps in it okay whoa boom I did not see
that oh boy
oh hello alright I needed more lava
anyway as I need sand dirt deert a Joe
dear Tay alright come on now come on my
useless peeps
gah why can't I get a sandbag Brigade to
go dam up the water why do I have to do
everything myself cuz I'm so great is
the answer ten points to you if you said
I'm so great
ah right it's gonna take a while
I wonder why that's coughing out dirt
instead of you know just lava but it
really seems to be adding dirt I don't
know I've seen that before
okay all right let's see this one's got
too much water still need more oh yeah
look at that they're more more I say
yeah out of here water don't like see
you anyway
oh come on work all right
bring it on I got to control that lava 4
or else it's gonna take over keep it in
check
alright this you
it'll automatically add vegetation so
I'm not worried about ruining the dirt
at least I think it will maybe well who
knows who knows about these things
okay is that enough you good now if I
the pansy
can't stand a little water oh come on Oh
God car boom yeah yeah it's like it
blows up adds a little bit of lava which
I can control and then it adds dirt
which is real nice real nice of it I
think that should be enough oh come on
what are you big pansy it's just the
tiniest any bitty drop of water there
what a loser
Oh get out of here there we go there we
go finally like wusses I'm dealing with
a bunch of wusses Oh can't build air or
this water it's a little wet it's up to
our little pinky toes in water uh get
out of here I need some amplified breath
action this is going slow
all right come on now is something have
you populated that yet get busy with it
get freaky with it up lavas starting
again guy gave that under control
Oh what do you want what do you want
what is a problem I do not see a problem
probably cuz I'm not looking in the
right place what you're right there
literally right there what is the dealio
really that's a problem is that water is
it again little itty-bitty bit of water
that was it wasn't it oh you big wusses
you big pansies i oughtta Jack slap you
so hard
uh-huh defy the giant that grows before
our very eyes but where the tsunamis
okay of course of course our tsunamis
why wouldn't there be I think that's
maybe that's a hotel watering down
and why of course with this thing
suddenly start growing just as soon as
our people get here
my people my peeps alright what what did
I get all finally amplify the breath
about time
come on yeah
Oh get it Oh get it okay that's repelled
lava which I guess I'll need if I ever
let this get out of control all right
get away screen all right gotta get to
that one next cuz that one is infinite
earth
no that's jellify water damn I need
infinite earth where is that I don't see
it oh it's over there
okay all right more dirt
come on now yay dirt come on
okay let me get let me at least get them
here just like right there and then I
can get the you repel lava and be good
oh that didn't that was another volcano
where it was where's that oh [ __ ] okay
all right
oh right there's a repel water okay I
still don't see a tsunami coming but I'm
sure it will strike when I least
suspected from behind [ __ ] they are
damn tsunamis
amplified a breath yeah
oh look at me go
oh that lava needs to be taken care of
we're sure petitioner yeah know that
that yeah all right a little more little
more little more uh honey I need
infinite earth real quick girls like I'm
gonna lose it
cuz I'm sure this constantly picking up
and dropping off sand is exhilarating to
watch hello now get going
gags going slurp Oh big glob gigant with
globs I'm here sneer
splurt splat there we go okay yeah I'm
starting to lose control of that one
not good not good okay almost there with
that one I think they can get here with
this one yeah good not having a hissy
fit content to the water on the island
geez
damn it Jack Christmas all right okay go
in there with Alan
whoa what's that that's interesting is
that like a water volcano that would be
cool
I don't know what it's doing is it gonna
fill up the ocean can it can the ocean
really raise level with the amount of
water I want to know that I honestly do
because if it does that'd be cool but
also bad at the same time okay all right
this looks connected it's gonna build it
up yeah I'm not gonna risk taking sand
from there okay all right there we go
more more more guys take the lava
because if the lava starts spilling out
then oh it's already starting
okay I just got a hurry now oh I just
kind of buried the totem hope that's
okay okay can I go here ah yeah picky
bastards right jellify water just
because I can all right almost ah no get
back I need a I need to send people to
that that repelled lava lava of course
the thing I had in my hand but just a
second cuz I'm wasting the end of my
breath oh no oh no what are we gonna do
all right get that get that so you don't
die
okay all right almost there
little more little more little more okay
is that enough for you
nope where is it oh that you gotta be
kidding me
what a pathetic pansy you are oh you
need toughness lesson for me there you
about time yes go around the lock nuts
makes perfect sense
why would you go anywhere else
okay all right looks like they have a
little trouble getting up this taken
care of
markiplier takes care of everything as
always oh you still can't get up there
whatever pansies oh well [ __ ] now too
late now cuz you're all screwed this
ever just you know drop this off oh no I
just turned off my amplified brother
opps oh good it saves the cooldown okay
more suck it up up I need to build back
up my wall so it flows the other way
because that was really stupid of me
enough do that I need infinite earth
populate that damn place turn it turn
come on alright
Oh scheisse something I'm surrounded by
water nope nope no don't even try it
that's alright do not even riot okay all
I need some sand I'm here I'm here
okay no don't go that way
and people why don't you pop you oh [ __ ]
gel if I water OH
get out of here yeah Oh whoo damn man
okay this this volcano is becoming a
problem very big problem Oh what is the
problem
Jesus are you serious are you serious
right now really stop for that really
okay there you go are you happy now
what's wrong go-go people please there
you go okay let's go go there he go you
don't have much time you see that giant
wall of water that's about to destroy
you
oh man why isn't someone going here why
isn't someone going here
oh because they can't reach it sure Kaka
your poopy it's not gonna get there in
time
oh there's so bro they're so boned they
are boned bone good sir
okay now volcano is still a problem oh
boy oh here comes okay it seems to have
subsided a bit oh no oh you're okay you
big hands easy I don't know why did I do
that it's lava
it was lava how did I just lava them I'm
such an a-hole oh but at least the
tsunamis gone okay alright everything's
in crisis but no one's dying yet so I'm
gonna cut it here thank you guys so much
for watching and I will see you guys in
part 16 I don't know the next part of
let's play from dust bye bye